我們之前常常講到
半導體有叫做三五足
除了這個碳化系
還有包括生化家林化英
像最近光通訊在講的就是
林化英缺料這件事情
如果講這些名詞
聽起來很生意
但是運用到實際的上面
他們都是很重要的
例如說剛剛講到的碳化系
或是像公立元件的
它就是在揮打的
電力藍圖裡面很重要
那林化英這個更不用講了
只要股價漲大
都會研究的什麼聯亞全新了
但這個族群還能看高做低嗎
對 這裡配已經買了
買了
對 上個禮拜五
就是買這個禮拜三
上禮拜五買這禮拜三
對 所以現在這個禮拜五的還沒買
禮拜五的還沒買
對 所以我現在保命到禮拜三了嘛
對 所以禮拜五的應該是
明天可能晚上就可以開始來佈局
可是現在很貴了吧
現在會比較貴
明天晚上以後可能會
對 比較有機會買便宜一點
目前來講我看起來是說
他可能走橫向的這個Wist點
比較機會大一點
所以你也是不打腳派的
對 原因是他的量
除非你要攻到1.5兆
那才有機會打過這個所謂的前高
因為這Wist點剛好就在
大概1.5兆所謂的一個量能
那我覺得說現在來講
也不求他量一定要馬上攻出來
因為大家才剛調整
調整好心態
所以我覺得很走是這個好事情
因為很走以後
慢慢的可能搞不好越線又穿越過季線
對 那基本上就是說
這來講
現在慢慢的一個收斂以後
其實位置點我覺得還不錯
就是個股表現
今年還是有很多股票窗
利息性高 沒有錯
那今天大概
大家在談論的當然就是回答
這事情 好 800VDC的地圖
對 那因為800VDC呢
這個透過回答這樣的事情
我覺得已經變成一個標準化
對 因為你可以發現說
目前來講他做的第一件事情說
二零二六年的下半年
他做的第一件事情是
原本很多劑房早就建置好對不對
所以原本是一個交流系統的
一個機房
現在來講就是把這個東西
就並 等於是直接可以
切入原本的這個交流系統的
一個機房
他跟很多家啦
Google Microsoft等等
大概聽說有八十個
那基本上ocp這個呢
也是共同開發這個架構
所以未來整個生態系來講
就是800VDC這個就會建構成
以後等於是直接進到這個機房
就直接是DC
是
對 等於是一個直流的一個環境
這樣子
等於是說這個地圖
其實它涵蓋的零組件
真的非常多
而且是一定要做的一件事情
那我們來看
就是我基本上把它稍微列出來
你會發現
那比如說在這個所謂的
這個800
800伏的這個高壓直流
對不對這個概念來講
你會發現總體來講
那當然大家前面看到
就是台達電視跟光寶科
對但是二哥比較厲害
對
那主要他基本上當然是
整個800伏的這個
機櫃裡面
他整個模組化相關的解決方案
基本上這兩個等於是最大
那下面來講
當然就會有其他的
之前講的康書跟這個ASKY
那就是所謂的BPU
對 等於在這個所謂的八百伏的
這個電力裡面
下面會掛了一個BPU的一個系統
所以這一塊來講
也是屬於這個八百伏的這一塊
那最後來講就是說
這裡可能很多人
比較沒有去看到
就是你總要有很多零件
對 那現在零件來講
今天一直在講SIS碳化系
那碳化系為什麼會提到碳化系
這個事情
就是說基本上
因為碳化系有耐高壓
耐高熱 是
那同時呢
他可以把他這個損耗降低
所以這樣的一個情況下
來講就是可以符合這個高壓直流裡面
那這個零件來講就相對重要
因為你還是要把它小化
對不對 縮小化
然後另外來講要耐高壓 耐高的
所以這裡面來講
我們大概可以看
就是說所以開始來講
當然是大家會看
所有的這個龍頭這兩隻 對
雖然光寶可是創高
但它是溫和的
對 他比較公平 他也不是爆噴式的
所以師公剛剛也提到
還有機會再往上走
可是對他來講
就是說大家可以看就是說
基本上他跟那個
我們講說台達電的對應呢
台達電在2000
2500多這樣下來
2500多下來的時候
他2500多他還在接近200的一個位置
那來講 現在來講
他已經創高到286
那台達電是回到這個2000以下
所以以這樣來看就是說
看高做低這個事情
我覺得是還是有利的
你意思是現在法人
你可能會 法人回去看一下
對 你就說台達電
已經整理過來
然後在右下角再做整理的
那台達電來講
現在剛好在右下角就整理
我覺得台達電基本上還是有機會了
那他基本上對他講也是有機會
因為他第二季的收益真的非常好
剛好看到大概第二季
大概三塊多嘛 三塊一
那比第一季來講
等於是這個成長是倍數的一個成長
那康初來講
我覺得說他基本上剛好第二劑發出來的財報比較差一點
對 因為之前有提到
我們今天剛好也幫大家再做一下追蹤
對不對
他就變成一個在一個區間小整理
一直不上不下
那因為他本來在這一塊裡面
BPU裡面是佔了一個很重要
是 800VDC這一塊
而且會價位低
那最重要的是他第二劑可能有一些一些開銷
開銷費用
對 費用剪掉以後
變成說他第二劑的這一片是降下來
可是他營收是上來的 是沒有問題的
對 所以這一塊我覺得說大家可能要忍耐
這一塊來講就是說長遠看
他的下半年大家還是看好了
對 因為今年還是大概法人是供他接近到
到這個這個快三塊左右
所以看起來他下半年
如果是能夠一計大概達到一塊錢左右
那基本上是有可能是往上購入
好 等放量對不對
這兩天量也急縮
因為至少還站在月線之上
我覺得還好
好 幫大家追蹤
強茂 公路元件也是大家很關注的
那基本上剛有看到兩個部分
就是在這個湯花系裡面
那基本上強茂做的是
所謂的這個元件
比如說他是做這個
所謂的湯花系
就是二級體的一個部分
所以這個元件基本上
在這裡面 工具元件裡面
它前面有一個題材
就是漲價題材
它跟被動
就是被動跟主動
都是一座山
它漲價題材起來以後
連續噴了三根漲體
對
整理過後又攻
那這一塊來講
基本上這漲價是確立的
是
所以以他來講
就是說
為什麼我特別畫這個圖
就是說其實在這樣的一個
位置點來講
我們之前有講過
當他越過前高開始攻的時候
那基本上就是一個
我所謂的一個支撐
那另外來講
這是一個另外的一個漲價的起漲點
那現在來講
剛好又回到漲價的一個起漲點
對啊 真的就回到原點
那對於高點來講
這個落差還很大
所以我倒覺得說
以這個點
剛好他也落在所謂的一個月線之上
那我倒覺得說有發亮攻擊的時候
基本上他還是有機會做一個
所謂的一個拉伸的一個動作
而且他這邊其實殺下來的時候
這邊都沒有亮對不對
對
所以他要往上克服應該是
還需要打一點亮起來
因為這裡面基本上這個亮
是有大概五萬張
在這個地方
到這邊會有壓力
所以如果有一點亮拉伸的話
他基本上還是有機會
公眾元件也是很多散戶
沒有套在裡面
那基本上我特別講一下
就說嘉金這一隻
很多人也沒有注意到
因為嘉金這一隻來講
他是做碳化系裡面的
等於是比較上游
有一點類似什麼
類似我們講零化
一直看這個三年八一的這個聯亞
對 那他是做累晶的一個部分
對他來講
他已經開始怎麼樣
收益不錯
從這個毛利七點九趴
到二零二六年Q2
已經達到二十三點五趴
所以他的這個
一片去年虧錢的情況下
今年第二季已經達到
轉會為贏
對轉會贏就是大概已經比第一劑
大概多了百分之八十九
八十九的這個這個這個計成長
那以這樣來講
就是說確實在這一塊裡面
我覺得說
如果碳化系這個需求起來
那最源頭基本上這個
這個累積部分
我覺得他是有機會
那因為年增確實是不錯的
那另外還有一個就是說
他其實不只是碳化系這一塊
是
對他基本上在這裡
有一個所謂的西光紙的一個引擎
所以他認為說在二零二六年
下半年以後
開到二零二七年會發動
因為這塊來講
就是說確實啦
在這一塊
他等於是在在
光通訊的這一塊裡面的這個基礎
這是什麼
這是者細跟什麼
這比較難念
者細跟所謂的一個累晶的部分
所以這一塊來講
那我覺得說這一塊是有機會的
所以以這樣的一個成長動能來講
就是說基本上今年大概有看到大概三塊錢左右
我們看一下 今年大概看得到三塊錢
明年可能預估
反正估得很好 估到接近八塊
不過像這種燙花系類的
他們的獲利波動真的很大
獲利波動很大
那我覺得說他也是一樣
就是說前面這個也都是因為
這個細光的一個部分
那產生了一個細菁源的部分
拉動起來
那我覺得說現在拉回來修正過後
也是一樣
就是說當他的錢高回來
變成一個支撐以後
那現在打上去站在月線之上
我覺得說這個都還有機會
再供上去的一個機會
之前謝金遠大來講說
怎麼都是這個環球金和金
怎麼不講一下家金
他也有他的功能
所以今天也有來幫大家聊到
未計確實是裡面比較好的地方
沒錯 因為看2027年
基本上如果估了這麼好
那還是有機會
希望能達到
因為這個族群以前
就是破裂破洞超級大
那現在我們也看了一下
這個靈化因
很紅喔
也是今天的一個重點
那因為林花英裡面的代表做
林雅 林雅跟全型
林雅又快要創高
又快要創高
就很恐怖
因為你會發現
那確實還是
他的七月營收來講
也是創高的
也是厲害的
對 那歪歪來講是
是一百七十六趴
對 那雖然說
他的收益來講
感覺是剛在起步
那因為今年來講
估值大概在二十塊
可是我們想說明年
估值是翻倍
所以為什麼他會拉到這種千元
就是說大家看他未來持長性
因為他也是等於是這個
林化嬰的源頭
對 源頭
所以基本上這一次來講
可能大家會看說
這個聯亞的部分
那另外來講就是這三隻
就是等於是以前這樣
PA三雄
PA三雄 文貿群星紅結科
對 那其實紅結科呢
比較少人去提到
其實他也有切入這一塊
上個禮拜一啊
有一個人提到
他現在在後面
對 就是施工
那因為你看喔 他基本上
他的收益也不錯喔
他上倍也將近大概三塊錢
對 因為才120塊
他是最便宜的啦
因為這裡面來講
全新營造400塊
我貿易經驗400塊
沒錯
對 那120塊來講
他現在的本益比就只有21倍了
因為你要接近他所謂的一個
我們講說
這個細光的部分
那基本上這個
本益比都非常高
那到明年來講
如果估到6塊多
他等於是只有到20倍左右
那我們來看一下
做什麼事情
因為我先看一下聯亞
快要創高的聯亞
所以我覺得說他有機會
我覺得明天就有機會
拉到這個高點的位置
前面還有一個高
因為我覺得三千多塊
對 沒錯
三千多塊
那全新的部分來講
就是說確實
這來講也是一樣
也是差一點點就要拉上
這個位置
今天都非常強勢
就開盤沒多久已經鎖掌平了
那所以說
今天如果整個看起來來
洪杰柯這一階
為什麼會特別談到洪杰柯
因為剛有提到
以前大家都認為他是在PA的部分
對啊 手機
他真正在切入的部分
光束包模組已經有出來了
所以光束包這VCL這塊呢
基本上是他已經開始有
這個啟動他的一個布局
那最重要是剛講PD
PD我們講說
這個所謂的光偵測的一個部分
這個就是所謂的
我們講說
在這裡需要所謂的靈化音
如果你現在來講
就是說現在本來靠這個
PA的一個部分
他就可以賺到2026
接近五塊錢
那明年的話 估值大概是到6塊多
到2028年大概8塊多
這個可能就是因為這個所謂的一個
這個GPU的部分
產生了這個收益出來
所以我覺得說以這一塊來講
它是蠻有機會的
那以現土來講
就是說確實這一波來講
本來它是非常漂亮
一個上升軌道
那在這裡就是說7月份
就是剛好破了這個所謂的
上升軌道的下源
確實來講 對它來講
就是一個比較偏空的一個部分
可是現在重新又站回月線
我就是說以他現在來講說
站回月線之後
這個所謂的上升軌道的下遠
會變成他的壓力
對 不過這壓力點離這個
120左右的位置點非常遠
大概還有百分之
接近三成的一個位置
所以我倒覺得說
以這一塊來講說
他一樣有量能攻擊的時候
基本上你不要忘了說
他跟這個靈化鷹的
這一塊的一個相關性很強
所以我覺得說還是非常有機會
所以等於雲祥哥會從題材面對不對
同族群已經有人在創高了
可是他位置卻很低
但是也要有條件齊聚
例如說他要有量能放出來
所以我們可以先把它放進觀察名單
或是先布一點局
等到量放到再來作家
沒錯
這邊非常謝謝雲祥哥
剛剛好像又進入到了化學課一樣
不過這些三五族確實可以
應用在各領域在AI上面
也是不可或缺的關鍵原料
像剛剛講到的家晶
他有談話系相關的
不管是電力 細菌源等等的運用
其他的佈局範圍是非常廣
重點在轉虧瘟疫
現在法人對他明年的期待是非常高的
至於林花英不用講了
因為股價已經表態了
那同族群裡面有股價表態的
自然也有相對比較落後的
就等他的發動量跟市場認同
我們都是可以先來做鎖股觀察的
今天非常謝謝三位的朋友
來到現場
台股的暗潮從上個禮拜五
在四萬六附近就有點盡觀情趣
但是可以看到在各族群
有領頭羊表態的情況下
AI的這股熱潮
其實默默的
是在內部發光發熱的
也代表台股在往新高邁進的路上
是不會急摸的
那也希望今天理財單秀
對您投資有幫助
明天再會了 拜拜